guess who's on the phone line right now
last time he was on he's like it was my
last appearance as an espn guy and like
i don't know where i'm
i can't tell you where i'm going we're
now we know where he's going he just
finished up
watching to weigh in for ufc 264.
uh he is now going to be covering the
ufc
for the ringer spotify and bt sports
our friend ariel helwani look at you mr
hyphenate
hello guys what about rich giving a
shout out to pink
boss baby and then coco is mentioned
competitor i mean we're trying to build
up something nice here
i'll say we love peacock in the helwani
household
uh but we like it for the wwe content
yes
over here my boys and i it's an absolute
must-have
and so shout out to the good people at
peacock here i am independent helwani
uninhibited uh mr eyes look at you shout
out anyone else
your freak flag fly man look at you
look at you uh all right well how how
was the weigh-in
what what what happened anything well
that's important so as
as you may know uh there's a two-hour
block where these fighters the 26
fighters competing on tomorrow night's
card can show up
i actually think the weins are at times
more interesting than the fights
themselves
because you really get a look at how
these guys are feeling how they look
what kind of weight cut they had
um you could show up at 901 you could
show up at 10 59.
the very first guy on the scale was
dustin poirier he made weight
156 he was good to go 18 or so minutes
later
conor mcgregor showed up he made weight
156 he predicted that he'd make 156 and
he'd be good to go
so the main event is good uh it is
official there was one mishap
uh one female fighter irene aldana uh
weighed in three and a half pounds over
the 136 pound bantamweight limit
she has to give up 30 percent of her
purse to her opponent yana kunitskaya
but other than that we are good to go
that's how they handle it huh they don't
just give her some time to just
you know so it depends you can't take
the extra hour
right uh every state is a little
different you can take an extra hour in
nevada
or you could say look i'm three and a
half over i'm going to pay the penalty
sometimes the opponent doesn't like that
and will ask for you to suffer because
they'll say
oh you're going to give up that 30
rather
easily uh maybe you didn't kill yourself
to get down to the
you know limit 136 in this case like i
did and you'll be fresher going into
saturday by the way
the records will show that the person
who comes in that much over typically
wins because they didn't
kill themselves on the way to the scale
so in this case she's taking the uh the
penalty and the fight will continue all
right so uh
by the way i respect poirier just
showing first thing up i'm the first guy
on the plane whenever my row is called i
gotta get on
you know um that's me you're the one
pushing everyone out of the way no i'm
the one getting on because i want to get
my stuff in the overhead bin and i want
to get situated i don't need anybody
else
putting stuff in the overhead bin you
know what i mean i need to get situated
so what uh you're always like seat one a
you know business super executive class
you don't have to worry about that
i don't need to see one i don't have to
flex like that i just need to be in the
first few rows while brockman walks past
me and i give him a stare down you film
it and i do sometimes dude
films it ariel i see it he seat shames
me when we're on the same flight
meanwhile rich is in probably what like
1b 2a whatever
i'm in six c like i'm not that far back
no you're you're
but you're more you're more of a you're
more of a d and an e guy yeah you're
right i'm window
i go right to sleep uh before i let you
go cause we do have the old heart out
how do you see the big fight going down
tomorrow night what's your thoughts here
oh my look at you
uh asking okay so i will say uh the fans
are going to be the winners
how about that one how about that
sitting on the fence all right and uh
i will also say i think it's going to go
longer than the first two fights first
fight but ended in the first round
second fight ended in the second round
i actually think this might go the
distance i think it's going to be really
close
uh i think it's a topic right now
conor's a slight underdog i
i think he's worth picking a flyer but
if you tell me right now you've seen the
fight in dustin juan i believe you've
let me see the fight conor want
i believe you these guys are very very
evenly matched but if you're looking to
bet
connor being the dog i think it's worth
a look ariel helwani
um uh do you want to respond to a
shirtless nikita kucharov saying that
montreal canadian fans acted in there
that they
that they won the cup with their one
stanley cup final win did not want to
uh validate that jabroni's comments
shape or form listen we were the 18 seed
we had no business
even being there they're 18 million over
the salary cap they bought their way to
a championship we did it the old hard
fashion way with
youngsters like cole caufield and nick
suzuki we will be back
we will be there the lightning are gonna
have to break up because they try to uh
break the rules here and buy themselves
a championship
congratulations no one cares about
hockey in tampa bay the city of montreal
should be very
proud of le abi tall okay what's more
likely to happen
khabib fighting again or uh somehow some
way on planet earth
damien lillard winds up a nick what do
you think oh my gosh
uh what's more
and guess what's going to happen here's
the prediction dame doll is coming to
the mecca
the knicks will be on fire msg will be
the center of the basketball universe
rich eyes is going to try to jump back
on the bandwagon and i'm going to
stiff-arm
here's your last chance i like the post
espn
i like it he's free i like it look at
you
all those guys at espn who've been
laughing at the knicks
for the last 10 years none of you and
you know what i'm talking about
kellerman company
none of you are allowed on the bandwagon
again you made your point
you put your your your flag in the sand
your brooklyn guys now
when dame dollar comes to the mecca in
about i don't know
a month or so you're not allowed on the
bandwagon i'm table today
all right ariel have a good time at the
fight congrats on your new landing spots
plural
thanks for the call thanks guys right
back at you ariel helwani
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here